Aujourd'hui, on est dans un parc et voyons ce qu'on trouve au milieu du lac.
Vous êtes prêts ?
Regardez, il y a Rasta en face
Ok.
Il y a quelques trucs.
Une barre de fer.
Et une pièce.
Oh, yeah.
Une boucle d'oreille
Yeah, une boucle d'oreille
Tu vas être mouillée ici Nicky
Ah, désolé
4 piles
Bien joué
Oh !
Elle est pleine ? Ah non
Une autre batterie
Qu'est-ce qui se passe ici ?
C'est incroyable de trouver autant de piles.
On rappelle qu'une seule pile peut suffire
Pour contaminer je ne sais pas combien de mètres cubes d'eau.
Donc c'est terrible.
Qu'est-ce que c'est ?
Une grosse pile
Une grosse pile, c'est fou
C'est quoi, 5 piles ?
Ouais.
Lancé d'aimant !
Ok.
Oh, non.
Tu as un téléphone !
Oui un portable
Oh, yes.
Les gens s'assoient ici et perdent leurs téléphones
Oh mon dieu !
Des munitions !
C'est des munitions à blanc
A blanc oui
Oh, my gosh.
Le type de trouvaille vient de changer rapidement
Je garde le téléphone
Super
C'est fou, regardez tout ça
Vous avez vu ?
C'est des munitions à blanc.
Donc une sorte de clip entier de munitions à blanc.
Peut être qu'elles étaient dans une caisse.
On va continuer à lancer.
Merci beaucoup
Thank you.
On a aussi le téléphone.
C'est ce que c'est ?
Beaucoup de poids
Ah, oui.
Qu'est-ce que c'est ?
C'est du matériel de pêche
Ouais, c'est une bouteille
Une bouteille en plastique euh...
Utilisée pour faire un poids
Oui c'est ça
Ok.
Oh, alors c'est que des petits objets,
mais en quelque lancés on a déjà fait tout ça.
Bien sûr, moi je préfère quand même ça.
Puis on voit avec leur état qu'ils ont été jetés il y a un petit moment
C'est des clips entier de munitions
Si, je pense que c'est des munitions pour le FAMAS.
Oui pour s'entraîner
Ils se sont entrainés il n'y a pas longtemps dans le coin, d'ailleurs.
Ouais, mais là, elles sont vieilles.
J'aime bien parce qu'on est vraiment dans un parc,
donc ça paraît improbable de trouver tout ça.
Et quand même, il y a des dizaines de piles électriques,
Il y a des objets à insolites
Et surtout, il y a eu les munitions
qui étaient, je pense, à l'entrée du parc.
Ce qui est logique.
Quelqu'un qui cherche à se débarrasser de munitions,
il les jette le plus tôt possible.
Donc, on va continuer bien cet endroit
avant de faire le tour du lac et d'aller vers là-bas
où il y a d'autres parkings
et des possibilités de jeter des objets un peu plus gros.
Ça m'étonne qu'il n'y ait pas de vélo, ouais.
Ouais.
Bah, ouais, c'est vrai.
Ah, Rasta est revenu.
Un limonadier ?
Banyuls et ?
Collioure
Ah bah oui, se sont des villes.
Banyuls-sur-mer et Collioure
C'est sympa.
On est dans le coin.
Essayez de l'enlever doucement, là, de ne pas le casser,
parce que c'est peut-être restaurable, ça.
Ouais, il est peut-être restaurable,
celui-là, le joli limonadier.
Domaine...
Ah, mais c'est le nom du domaine, alors ?
Ouais, c'est un domaine.
Joli.
Sympa.
Belle trouvaille
Il sent très bon
Ah ! Bondi Treasure Hunter a quelque chose
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
Oula.
Vous devez aller sur la droite.
Super !
C'est un panneau
Je pense que cet endroit n'avait jamais été pêché à l'aimant
C'est bon signe
C'est très bon signe
Et ça, c'est aussi un très bon panneau
Ouais.
Oh.
Yes.
Là, j'ai quelque chose.
Il y a quelque chose de gros ici
Oui, c'est gros
Oh, c'est gros
Est-ce que c'est un coffre fort ?
Oui, ca peut être un coffre fort
Oh, man.
Vas-y Baptiste, envoie ton aimant
Il est juste là
Je peux essayer de le renverser
Oh !
Qu'est-ce que c'est ?
Oh, c'est une plaque d'égout
C'est une plaque de fluviale
Ok.
C'est cool.
On va vider le lac
Oui.
C'est la bouchon pour le lac.
Oui, oui.
Allez, on continue Quentin, qu'est-ce que tu en penses ?
C'est bien, la plaque d'égout, ça me va.
Une plaque fluviale d'ailleurs.
Ouais, ouais, fluviale
Jolie plaque fluviale
Oh, j'ai peut-être fait une météorite là.
Une roche bien magnétique.
Regarde.
Peut-être un meteorite.
Meteorite.
Oh, ouais.
C'est vraiment magnétique.
J'adore sa forme
Ouais, c'est un peu bizarre.
Parce que c'est comme,
Les météorites sont lisses à l'extérieur comme ça
Ouais.
Ok.
Elle est intéressante
Ouais.
On va le vérifier.
Il y a quelque chose de gros là encore.
Il prend des risques, il descend
Ca peut être glissant
Ok.
C'est à peu près 5 euros au prix de la ferraille
Ouais.
C'est un espèce de...
De morceau de poutre en acier.
Alors Quentin, qu'est-ce que tu penses de cet endroit ?
Ah, j'aime bien, hein.
Il n'y aura surement pas trop de coffres fort
mais on peut trouver des choses intéressantes
Bah, déjà, les munitions,
ça m'a fait plaisir.
Ça a montré que c'est possible, quoi.
Rasta
Non, tu n'auras rien.
Allez, Rasta
Ca suffit
Tu laisses pour les poissons.
Allez.
Allez, filles.
Filles.
C'est pour les poissons.
Allez.
Tu n'es pas un poisson.
Pas encore.
Allez, filles.
Vas voir Quentin.
Vas voir les croquettes là-bas.
Tu veux jeter un coup?
Allez, on va voir ce que t'as trouvé,
pas sûr qu'il y ait quelque chose mais on ne sait jamais
Ah rien.
Mais bien essayé
Si tu as eu ça
un caillou.
Voilà ta trouvaille
Allez, on continue de se décaler le long de ce lac
et là, je viens de faire encore une énorme pile
Désolé pour le vent.
Une batterie énorme.
Là, j'ai quelque chose
qui était au bord.
Je l'ai perdu.
OK.
Ils sont dessus
Il y a quelque chose ici, c'est sûr
Un handspinner !
Bien joué
Vous voulez un Handspinner ?
Je pense qu'il ne fonctionne plus
Oui, je m'en doutais.
Je m'en doutais.
Je le savais !
Qu'est ce que tu as eu ?
Je savais que c'était ça
Oh c'est une trottinette
Regardez !
Une petite écrevisse
C'est une mini écrevisse
OK, veux tu que je l'attrape ?
Oui, tu peux.
Il faut l'essayer
Oui, tu vas l'essayer ?
Attention, ne te salie pas.
Ne te salie pas, attention.
Oui, c'est bon.
Oui.
Bonjour.
Bonjour
A qui appartient le chien ?
A moi, à nous
Ah, il faut le l'attacher ?
Ah, OK.
Encore là, ça va, les canards, ils ne sont pas là
Ah oui, c'est pour les canards.
Bon, j'ai discuté avec le policier rural, qui était super sympa.
Il m'a dit que l'endroit n'avait pas été vidé depuis 15 ans, donc depuis 2008.
Et qu'ils avaient déjà repêché une voiture et des coffres forts.
Oh!
Le policier m'a dit que je vous laisse vous amuser, travailler.
Et j'ai dit ben pareil.
Ah, j'ai quelque chose.
Un morceau de panneau
Ils l'ont plié.
C'est difficile de le sortir
Tu as entendu ça ? Un bruit de coffre fort
Quentin, ça a été un bruit, comme un coffre fort.
Ce n'est pas un coffre fort
Oh, c'est OK.
Oh, my God.
OK.
C'est une barrière
Je pensais vraiment que c'était ça
Tu as quelque chose ?
Ah, qu'est-ce que c'est...
Oh!
OK.
Une demi trottinette
Alors, c'est lourd ?
On espère que vous avez apprécié cette petite dernière vidéo
en présence de Bondi Treasure Hunter.
C'était la dernière qu'on a tournée durant son séjour en France
On arrive la semaine prochaine
avec une nouvelle vidéo plus longue que celle-ci.